[Music]
so far we are still eagerly awaiting the
animated sequel minions the rise of gru
which has been postponed several times
and is scheduled to hit theaters next
july universal pictures and illumination
have now jointly announced that they are
already hard at work on further sequels
from the minions universe accordingly
the fourth part of the despicable me
series around the villain grew is
already being planned however the movie
will not be released for over two years
on july 3 2024 certainly with great hope
on the part of those responsible after
the first three parts have crossed over
2.5 billion us dollars worldwide
director chris renau who also supervised
the first two movies is responsible for
the suitable realization while the
script will be from emoji movie author
mike white illumination is also working
on another animated movie called
migration which is scheduled for release
in june 2023 it's about a duck family
that wants to spend the vacation of a
lifetime together far away from home
director john turtletop scored a real
hit in 2018 with mack the blockbuster
about the extinct giant shark megalodon
was able to convince viewers worldwide
with sometimes simple but still
captivating action the hype around mac 2
is correspondingly great where we
recently received further information
about the cast after a long period of
silence from the responsible parties
according to this in addition to the
returning lead actor jason statham we
will also see the two resident evil
afterlife stars siena gallory and sergey
peres manchetta as well as american
horror story actress scala samuels the
latter will play an adventure while
paris manchetta will portray a villain
and guillory scientist not much is known
about the plot so far except for the
somewhat meaty title the trench this is
a possible hint that the main actors
will go even deeper into the sea
possibly to encounter much more alarming
creatures than the already gigantic
megalodon and the novel by steve alvin
the scientists discover a chronosyrus in
the second book also called the trench
the prehistoric monster which can be
over 10 meters long and weighs 11 tons
is equally likely to cause terror and
could outrun the megalodon by the way
the director in the second part is no
longer john turtletop about ben wheatley
when exactly mack 2 the trench will be
released is not yet known
after we already got early glimpses of
certain outfits and scenes by various
toy makers in spiderman no way home it
seems to be similar for the upcoming
thor love and thunder in particular the
focus is on lead actor chris hemsworth
and his two colleagues natalie portman
and christian bale the two high-profile
hollywood stars play the characters
mighty thor and gore the godbutcher
pictures of bayless gore are scarves at
the moment but bale could be seen in
public at times last year with a bald
head which probably has something to do
with his new role a lego set of all
things now gives us a glimpse of gore in
the accompanying article from screenrant
we see the figures cork valkyrie mighty
thor thor and the god butcher himself
the antagonist wears an almost all-white
rope and his famous all black the
necrosword which gives him almost
overpowering powers collider also
reported on a lot of new toys from the
hasbro company again the simple looking
figures reveal more than meets the eye
as they seem to reveal among other
things what thor's destroyed hammer
mjolnir is all about we see deep cracks
in the material of both the mighty thor
figures accessories and the actual
plastic mjolnir which leads us to
believe that the hammer was patched up
after the events of thor ragnarok and is
now available to mighty thor alongside
her we also see thor and cork as well as
the official stormbreaker toy we're
definitely excited to see what the
characters look like in the finished
movie and of course we'll keep you
updated on more thor love and thunder
news the release of the movie is
scheduled for july 8th 2022
disney's next mcu movie doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness will
finally be released in theaters in may
especially after the second trailer
which was shown for the first time at
the super bowl many fans can't stop
speculating in the original version of
the second trailer for example you can
hear a voice that sounds suspiciously
like patrick stewart as professor x when
asked about the trailer stuart denied
his involvement saying it wasn't the
first time others had imitated his voice
this statement was somewhat confusing
after all it was actually certain that
stuart wasn't born as a member of this
so-called illuminati ryan reynolds was
also asked whether the x-men and
especially he as deadpool would not
celebrate their mcu debut in the doctor
strange sequel he himself also affirmed
like patrick stuart that they are not
involved in the movie in any way is this
the biggest bluff since andrew
garfield's denial of spiderman norway
home or is disney really trying to pull
the wool over eyes with a fake professor
x-boys we'll probably only find out when
the movie is released on may 6 2022
last year the tomorrow war was the first
collaboration between chris pratt and
amazon prime video as has now been
officially announced pred's next amazon
project has already been given a new
start date it's a thriller series the
terminalist which revolves around navy
seal commander james reese played by
pratt and is watering their mission in
afghanistan after a taliban ambush
nearly the entire team is wiped out
while rhys returns home severely
traumatized and wrecked with guilt he
later realized that dark deeds are
probably behind his fate and are working
against him in addition to pred other
stars on board include taylor kitsch as
ben edwards constance wu as katy
perronick riley coke as lauren reese and
patrick schwarzenegger as donnie
mitchell the terminalist is scheduled
for release on amazon prime video on
july 1 2022
fans of netflix mystery hit stranger
things have had to be particularly
patient in the past concerning the new
season now however there is finally
reason to rejoice as the two stranger
things creators matt and ross duffer
recently announced in a letter the
fourth and presumably penultimate season
will soon be released the two brothers
who first presented their successful
series on netflix in the summer of 2016
explicitly emphasized the planned end
the story arc has been completed for
many years and has since been limited to
four to five seasons apparently it
should remain that way which should
prevent unnecessary delay of the plot
season 4 will be released in two parts
one after the other on netflix the
reason for this is the significantly
longer running time compared to the
predecessors which will nevertheless
only spread over nine episodes overall
however they're stuck of a run time that
is almost twice as long as that of the
previously released seasons in terms of
content season 4 picks up
chronologically from the events of
season 3 and takes almost 6 months after
the battle of stockhold the team group
consisting of dust and lucas will mike
and elle must cope for the first time
with the fact that they are separate
from each other for a large part of the
time in addition they later have to face
a new threat from the outside also
included is a rather creepy house which
we could already see in the teasers and
trailer as main actor gate madarasa also
confirmed the new season will be darker
and scarier than ever before stranger
things fans can look forward to not only
many familiar faces but also a few new
actors among them are for example freddy
krueger actor robert eglin as the crazy
victor creel eduardo franco as funny
pizza boy argyle and jamie campbell
bauer as psychiatric nurse peter ballard
by the way on a recently published image
on the twitter channel of stranger
things you can see a mysteriously
designed poster in addition to the start
dates it starts with season 4 volume 1
on may 27th while the second part then
appears on july 1st 2022
in the gaming world fallout has been a
household name for almost 25 years now
the franchise could also manage to
conquer the hearts of fans in a series
so far nothing new but after many months
of uncertainty we finally know the first
actors sign on for the amazon project
the talk is of django and the hateful
eight actor walton goggins who is to
play one of the yet unnamed main
characters the series will be produced
in collaboration between amazon game
developer bethesda and written by
westworld writers lisa joy and jonathan
nolan it is also nolan who will direct
the pilot episode fallout while geneva
robertson dwarit will serve as
showrunner in terms of content the
fallout games are primarily about a
post-apocalyptic world in which you as
the protagonist have to achieve your
individual goals depending on the story
and the latest installment fallout 4 for
example you play a character in the year
20 to 87 who is searching for her son
and has to go on an odyssey in an
earlier installment fallout new vegas
the flood revolves around the courier
who in search of a stolen platinum chip
gets to know various factions of this
so-called wasteland and experiences all
sorts of wacky things the mixture of
black humor crazy game world and a
multitude of iconic characters could
thus be excellently transferred to the
series even though the expectations of
the gaming community are often rather
low when it comes to game adoptions
nevertheless we are still eagerly
awaiting news about amazon's fallout
series which unfortunately does not have
an official release date yet
if you enjoy our news this week be sure
to check out our latest original on the
lord of the rings the rings of power
there you'll learn all about the details
that can be seen in the first trailer
and the possible plot of the new amazon
series we also recommend the new trailer
for the upcoming animation movie the bad
guys on our channel
[Music]
you